We are talking about
semiconductors today.
Yeah.
I finished
our exam 2 concept
math that I thought maybe
you guys would find useful.
This is much like the
last time, when I gave you
guys the concept map.
I'm just giving it a
little earlier this time.
And here, you can see
all the connections
between the lectures, the
recitations, the problem
sets, the quizzes over here,
the goody bags, and the exam
topics.
Speaking of the quizzes,
tomorrow, there's a quiz.
And so you can look up here
and say, OK, well, what's
going to be on that quiz?
Might cover some
molecular orbital theory.
Might cover the band gap
stuff that we did on Monday
and that you covered in
recitation yesterday.
Oh, and intermolecular
forces we also did.
And you're asked to
bring to the quiz
the voltmeter and
these large LEDs.
Now, I'll talk about that, a
little bit more about this,
in a few minutes.
So remember to bring that.
Laura will also send a
reminder email about that.
OK, you have voltmeters.
You and voltmeters.
How many of you, this
is the first time
you're using a voltmeter?
How many of you haven't used
one but you've never seen one--
you've used it before,
but you've never
had one this accurate
as the 3091, right?
Yeah.
You never know when
you need a voltmeter.
You should always carry it with
you with the periodic table.
Now, on Monday,
this is what we had.
This was a conduction band.
This was a valance band.
And then we had a
conduction band and valence
band that were a little
bit closer together.
And then, we had this
case, where maybe it's
filled up somewhere in
the middle of the band.
And remember, the valance
band is filled with electrons,
and the conduction band is not,
right, in the simplest picture.
And this difference in
energy between this VBN--
that's the VBN, the maximum
level of the valence band--
and the CBN--
the minimum level of
the conduction band--
that energy difference is
the gap of the material.
Here, you can see
energy gap equals zero.
Well, in this
case, it's a metal.
Or if you want,
it's a conductor.
And we'll talk about why it's
a conductor more on Friday,
but a little bit today,
why metals are conductors.
Today, I really want
to focus on this case.
All right, so that's
a metal when there
is no gap in the material.
If the gap is large, then
that is an insulator.
What do I mean by large?
Well, what I mean is it's not in
the range of this special case,
which would be, say,
zero less than the gap
less than around
3.5 electron volts.
This is the case that I
want to talk about today.
I want to spend today
talking about semiconductors.
Those are called semiconductors.
Let's write that here.
Semiconductors.
Sometimes you'll see
them called metaloids.
Sometimes you'll see them called
insulators with small gaps.
They're all kind of right.
Metaloid, thank you.
Now, the reason why we classify
these and why this range of gap
is so important is what I
want to convey to you today.
These are really
special materials,
these semiconductors.
Now, before I do that, I want
to just clarify one thing.
And I'm going to use diamond
and graphite as an example.
On Monday, what we
did is we talked
about the concept of bands with
a very simple 1D model, right?
This was a 1D model of
s orbitals, 1s orbitals.
I said, well, if I have
a mole of 1s orbitals,
then that goes into a band.
And I called it a 1s band.
I always say, well,
if you fill it
in different ways, that is
what determines the properties.
But I want to be clear-- and
I stressed this on Monday,
and I want to stress it again.
Whether this forms this
and then the next set--
you know, whether
you get a 1s that
forms a band like
this and then a 2s
that forms a band like
this and then another one,
maybe 2p, like this.
Or whether there's
breaks in them,
or maybe these kind of overlap--
so you get overlap, and you get
sort of something like that.
All that depends on more than
just those atomic orbitals.
It depends on more.
It depends on how these
things are bonded.
This is such a great example.
I've got the same element here.
Its carbon.
There's nothing
else in this system.
Carbon, pure carbon.
Everywhere is carbon.
But on the one hand, I've
arranged it in a certain way.
And on the other hand, I've
arranged it in another way,
and their properties
couldn't be more different.
So just to take this
a little further,
if I think about diamond on the
left, diamond is an insulator.
Diamond has a gap of 5
and 1/2 electronvolts.
5 and 1/2 electronvolts.
It's an insulator.
But OK, that makes
me think of methane.
Remember, methane, you
had these SP3 states--
SP3, SP3, SP3.
And the reason it formed SP3
is because all these H1s states
came along--
H, H, H, H. These are 1s's, 1s.
And so carbon came along, and
it said, well, if I arrange--
if I got four of you here like
this and I arrange myself--
if I arrange my
orbitals in such a way
that then I can arrange so that
they're minimizing repulsions,
that gives me methane.
That gives me the
ground state of methane.
But the only way to do that
is to have four equivalent
orbitals.
Those are hybrid orbitals.
We talked about this when we
talked about hybridization.
The idea being that if I took
one of these and one of those--
so now you can imagine
how it's going to look.
You know all this now, right?
There's a 1s
orbital of hydrogen.
You know that those will
form a sigma and a sigma star
and occupy that bonding orbital.
That's the idea of methane.
That's the idea of
molecular orbital theory
with some hybridization.
And it's going to form those
bonds along each direction.
But now I'm talking about
something different.
I'm not talking about
such a simple case.
I'm talking about
one mole of SP3.
That's what diamond is.
Look, the carbon atoms
have done the same thing.
They said, hey, wait a second,
OK, it's not four hydrogens.
It's like 10 to the 23 carbons
all in one small space.
How can we organize
to lower our energy?
And so they form--
well, we know this, that
it's going to form a band.
But it doesn't just form a
band and then half fill it.
That's not what diamond does.
No, actually, diamond
breaks this apart so
that you have a huge gap.
And those are filled,
and then those are not.
The SP3 band in
diamond breaks apart
into a valence and
a conduction band.
The valance band is full.
The conduction band is empty.
Why?
Well, you don't need to
learn the specifics of how
to get from there to there.
But I wanted to show you
how complicated this is.
I will ask you whether the
SP3 band splits or not.
I just wanted to show you
how dependent this is.
Because now, look, you can
understand this now, right?
So I've got four electrons
per atom going here.
There's a huge gap, and
then nothing in there.
That's diamond.
5.5 eV gap.
One mole of SP3 in diamond.
Now, it depends
on the structure.
If I had just put them
together in some amorphous soup
with no--
oh, amorphous.
That's a word
that's coming later.
But if I just put them
together with no order,
I wouldn't get this,
this splitting.
You take graphene, which
is one of those sheets,
and make stacks and
you've got graphite.
It's another form
of pure carbon.
In that case, you've got your
SP2 bonds to form in the plane,
and those also
split and they fill.
But now you've got your pi
bonds, and those don't split.
So in graphite, what you get
is you've got your SP2's.
You've got a mole of those,
and you've got your P electron.
Remember those?
Now you do a mole of that,
and you've got the same thing.
But see now, you've got--
these are the SP2 bands.
It also split.
Remember, I've got
my electrons here,
my SP2 electrons
and those there.
But now, I've got the pi
bands that didn't split.
Graphite is a metal.
You can understand it
by looking at the bands
of these materials.
Now, again, let me
emphasize, I am not
going to ask you to
know when something
splits like this or not.
Why didn't the pi band split
into two like these did?
When does an S and a P become
a single band versus an S
band separated by a P band?
I'm not going to ask
you to know that,
but I wanted you to see it.
It doesn't just depend
on the initial states.
It depends on the
structure of those atoms.
It depends on how those
atoms are bonded together.
Now, what about
this semi-conductor?
What about this semiconductor?
Well, if we take a semiconductor
and we look at it--
I told you this on Monday.
There are two things that
you can do in your goody bag,
especially.
One is you can take an electron,
and you can shine a light
on it, and it's going to
excite this electron up, just
like in the Bohr atom, right?
You can absorb photons if the
photon energy is the energy
between one state and another.
We did a lot of this earlier.
But see, in a
semiconductor, remember,
I've got an almost infinite
number of states here.
And so what I need
is for that photon--
there's not an exact value here.
There's a continuum.
But here, it's forbidden,
just like in the Bohr atom.
There's no states.
There's no electron.
So here, the energy of
the photon absorbed--
let's write this out--
has to be greater than
the energy of the gap.
This is the energy of the gap.
Now, by the same token, I can
take the same semiconductor
and run it the other way.
I can put a current on
it and feed electrons,
electrons from current.
So I can attach it to a
battery, and there you go.
This is a semiconductor
where I'm literally--
all I'm doing is I'm feeding
electrons into its conduction
band.
But now, when those
electrons fall down
into the valence band,
they emit a photon.
Photon emitted.
And just so I have room, with
energy of the photon emitted
is going to be exactly equal
to the energy of the gap.
You can see that
because these electrons,
I might inject them into the
conduction band anywhere,
but they're going to
wind up very, very,
very quickly going to this
minimum conduction band state.
And that gets me to another
important point, which
is on the absorption side,
I can overshoot this.
Like I said, I can absorb
higher than the gap.
I can't absorb lower,
but I can absorb higher.
And if I do, if I absorb
higher than the gap--
so let's say this is my state.
So if my photon comes in and
it kicks in electron up really
high, it's a high-energy photon,
then that electron very quickly
will go back down.
And that's called
thermalization.
So what happens is that
electron loses energy
to heat to get to the CBM.
We'll come back to this later.
That's thermalization.
So the electron can be kicked
up by light to any level,
but it's going to very,
very quickly go to the CBM.
That's why when I
inject it-- that's
why these are the same color.
These are high-quality
LEDs, clearly.
Well, they work.
That's a good thing.
So the batteries might
be slightly different,
and the currents might be
different, a little bit.
I might be injecting
electrons at different parts
of these conduction bands,
but this is always green,
and this is always red.
And that's because those
electrons very quickly get down
to the CBM and the VBM.
And the CBM and the VBM are
determined by the semiconductor
inside.
Well, you've also got--
so this is a photon
emitter right here.
I've made a light
emitter, right?
But I've also got
a detector, which
here's what I said on Monday.
So now, I take an
LED, and I hold it--
gesundheit.
And this is what's
inside of the emitter.
It's the same thing.
It's a semiconductor.
But these two semiconductors
have different band gaps.
That's why the
light is different.
They have different band gaps.
Now I've got one
with some band gap,
and I hook it up to my
voltmeter, and I just look.
Is there a current or not?
If this thing
conducts through it,
it means that
electrons have been
promoted from here to here.
And that's something we're
going to talk about today.
Electrons cannot
move around easily
if they're in the valence band.
But once they're in that
conduction band, they're free.
How do I get them there?
Well, you've got power.
Shine red light on it.
Does it conduct?
Check the voltmeter.
I'm literally holding
two semiconductors
and doing these two processes
right here in each hand.
It's a power that I have.
I have semiconductor
making light, semiconductor
absorbing light, or maybe not.
If I shine right on this
and I get no current,
well, it means that the energy
of the photon from a red light
source is too low.
Maybe it's able to excite it
up to here but not up to here,
given whatever the
gap in here is.
You see that?
So the semiconductor has
this powerful-- maybe
I take a different semiconductor
and red excites it.
Or maybe it doesn't, so I go
to a higher energy photon.
With this goody bag,
you're touching and feeling
semiconductor physics
and chemistry.
Because band gaps in
materials are rare.
You see, if you look
at the periodic table
and you classify it by
metals, metals and nonmetals--
so insulators,
conductors, and then
these weird things in between--
there aren't that many of them.
There aren't that many of them.
But as you can see, these
are really, really important
technological materials.
Why?
Because this is visible light.
This semiconductor range
here is in the range of light
we care about--
visible, UV.
So I've got an
electronic material where
the electrons in it can interact
with currents, small currents
even, and wavelengths of light
that are things we can see.
You can imagine how important
this could be, for example,
for making LEDs.
But I need a lot more
flexibility in my material set,
and that's where
chemistry comes in.
So this is, one, why
this matters for today.
So, look, I mentioned
that getting red
was hard back in the
day for color TV,
because the red phosphorus
were difficult to make.
For LEDs, it was blue.
In fact, there was a lot of
work around gallium nitride.
Here's gallium nitride
in one structure.
Notice this.
There's gallium nitride.
It's not on here.
Darn it.
Gallium nitride in other
structures have different gaps.
Oh, there it is.
There's one.
But the point was
they wanted blue.
They wanted blue,
and they needed
to make a material that was
both cheap to make and lasted,
so it didn't degrade, and
gave you a blue light.
And that was really hard.
And that's what the Nobel
Prize was given for in 2014.
Because without blue, you
can't make white light.
So there's all sorts
of technologies
you simply can't go into
with LEDs until you get blue.
How did it happen?
It happened because of chemistry
because people figured out
how to change the how to take
one element another element
and then maybe
alloy them together.
Maybe you take gallium nitride
and you alloy a little bit
of aluminum in here.
That means mixing it in.
Now, all of a sudden, you've
got a different band gap.
Band gap engineering is
really the centerpiece
of the semiconductor revolution.
Now, the connectivity.
We've been talking
about connectivity.
And we'll talk about
metals on Friday.
Here we are.
Insulator's really low.
Least conducting,
10 to the minus 25.
Hook your voltmeter
up to Teflon.
10 to the minus--
wood.
Low-conducting materials.
But we're interested
in these, and these
are kind of in-between.
They're not very
good conductors.
That's why they're
called semiconductors.
But the fact of the matter goes
back to what I've been saying.
And this is the next point
I want to talk about,
which is I cannot have--
so in a semiconductor,
there's no electrons.
If there's no electrons
in the conduction band,
then there's no
electron conduction.
Now, I've said this before.
I said this on Monday.
I said it already.
Why not?
On Monday, I said, well,
these electrons are stuck.
What does that
mean, they're stuck?
Stuck in the bonds,
stuck in the anti-bonds.
They're stuck in states.
The point is, here, that
this valance band is filled.
Now, if I want an electron
to move through a material,
which is what conductivity
is, after all--
by the way, siemens,
conductance, one over ohms.
If I want electrons to move in
a material, they need freedom.
They need freedom.
What does that mean?
Well, it means that I'm trying
to move through this wire.
And for an electron,
freedom means
I can go to any
state that's nearby.
State, a wave function,
a state of probability
that I can move to.
And then to that one.
And then over here.
And then there's
is something there.
I don't want to be.
I've got to go this way.
There's a bad thing over there.
It's scattering me.
I'll go this way.
But if electrons
don't have the ability
to move into a free state,
they're not going to conduct.
That's why you've got to
get the electron up here.
Why?
Because the conduction band--
I shouldn't really fill this in.
I'm just showing you
empty states there.
The conduction band has
10 to the 24 states.
Freedom.
So as soon as an electron
gets up there, it's like, oh,
I can go anywhere I want.
I can be there.
I can move in response to this
field that's pushing at me.
I can conduct.
I can't do that unless
I have conduction,
unless I get electrons
into the conduction band.
This is OK.
Now, this is why, you can see
right there, metals are clearly
good conductors, based
on our band picture.
Because those electrons
near that line there,
you fill them up, and
they're halfway in a band.
But right up above there, an
almost infinitesimally small
energy away, is an empty
state and another empty state.
These ones you can see,
it's going to be hard.
I'm going to have to shine
really high energy light
to even get-- or really
high temperatures.
Again, semiconductors
are special,
because their gaps are
right in that range where
I can get electrons to
go from the valence band
to the conduction band
in different ways.
And there's two different ways
that I want to talk about.
The first way is
simply with heat,
and this is why I
mentioned this on Monday.
Actually, no matter
what, there's
some probability for
an electron to have
a high enough thermal energy.
Yeah, electrons get
hot, too, right?
Everybody feels the heat.
So that the thermal energy can
be enough to get the electron
to knock it up above.
So with thermal
energy, you can get--
let's see.
At room temperature for silicon.
So this is the case of silicon,
which has a 1.1 electronvolt
gap.
Silicon, 1.1
electronvolt band gap.
It's a really important
semiconductor.
And for silicon, at room
temperature, I got about 10
to the 10 electrons in the
conduction band per centimeter
cubed of material.
This is how we think about it.
We think about how many of
these do I have per volume.
It's a good way to measure it.
These are also an electron
in a conduction band
also is called a carrier.
So for silicon at room
temperature, I will have--
just because I can't help it,
because there's that many--
about 10 to the 10 carriers
in the conduction band.
Now, carrier is a
carrier of electricity.
That's why it's called
a carrier, right?
It carries electricity.
So those are the ones
that are carriers,
the ones that made it up.
But if I go to 600--
so now I'm going to
go to 600 kelvin.
Oh, we only use kelvin.
Kelvin is the
thermodynamic energy scale,
temperature scale.
10 to the 15 carriers
per centimeter cubed.
This seems like a big number,
but is it a big number?
What's a big number we know
and like in this class?
The mole.
So like roughly-ish, is
this all a big number
per centimeter cubed or not?
It's actually very small.
But I need them to be there
if I want better connectivity.
If I want conduction in
these semiconductors,
I've got to put electrons
up in the conduction band.
Do you remember, just
as an important point,
I mentioned the energy of room
temperature, the thermal energy
of room temperature kBT is
about 0.025 electronvolts.
That seems way
smaller than 1.1 eV.
It is.
But that's because that's
not what temperature really
looks like.
Temperature is a distribution.
There's a distribution.
Now, you don't need to know
that for the band gaps.
We're going to come
back to distributions,
Boltzmann distributions, when we
talk about reactions, reaction
kinetics, later.
But that's why, at room
temperature, the tails--
hot means a range of energies.
Hotter means a wider
range of energies.
And it's those tails
that have enough energy
to get over the gap and
into the conduction band.
It's those tails.
That's why I've got a little
bit of electrons that get
up there at room temperature.
Now, if you look at a plot--
here's a great way.
There's the log
connectivity of silicon.
It's from [INAUDIBLE].
And there's the log connectivity
on this side of tungsten.
That's a metal.
Totally different behavior.
How is that possible?
Well, we're going to
explain the metal on Friday.
Today, we're interested in this.
This one, now we understand.
Thermal energy excites
carriers into the place where
they can be free and conduct.
So as I increase the
temperature hotter and hotter--
there's the
temperature in kelvin.
I just gave you
examples from down here,
and now we're going
higher and higher.
I can get the connectivity
up orders of magnitude
higher for silicon.
You know why now.
I'm populating.
I'm getting over
this gap, and I'm
populating the conduction band.
So the answer is we just
need to run our semiconductor
industry and our phones and our
lights at around 1,000 kelvin,
right?
No problem.
All our devices.
No, that's obviously
not a good idea.
How do we get around this?
The answer, such a good
word, it's chemistry.
Chemistry gets us.
Chemistry saves us, as always.
You've got to know
your chemistry.
And in particular,
this is not the doping
that you may read about
in the news related
to Olympic athletes.
This is the introduction of some
small amount of an impurity.
An impurity is something
that wasn't there normally.
It's like something I mixed
in that's not normally there.
If I put a small amount
of something in it,
then I can tune the properties.
And in this case, I'm talking
about the connectivity.
So how does this work?
If I look at this case--
I'll do one case here.
I've got my silicon atoms
arranged in the solid that
gave me a band gap.
And again, that is due to
the arrangement of them.
If I didn't arrange them
in this particular way,
I might not have that band gap.
I might not have the
same band structures.
It depends.
But this is what I get for
the silicon arrangement
when the band gap is 1.1
eV, which is the one we
use in most of our electronics.
But the thing is, I want--
so this would be silicon.
This is just silicon by
itself, valance band,
and here's the
conduction band, CB, VB.
Now, I want to add electrons
into this material.
And so you can just
kind of imagine
how this would work, right?
If I just look at a Lewis dot
diagram for silicon-- let's
just forget about this
structure for a second.
Silicon has these four
valence electrons.
So you can imagine silicon
might look something like this.
And OK, I'm going along,
and I'm going along.
It's tetrahedral and stuff.
But now, I'm going
to take one out.
I'm going to take
this out, and I'm
going to make it phosphorus.
What is phosphorus?
It's, wait, where did it go?
Panic, and then--
I'm recreating what
happens for you guys--
I found it.
That was close.
But phosphorus is right there.
It's right next to silicon.
It's group 15 instead of 14.
But it just has one
extra electron, right?
So maybe it could
do the same thing,
but then have this
one extra electron.
That's doping.
Where does it go?
It's all about freedom.
It looks down and
says, wait a second.
There's no states
here I can go to.
No states.
I can't go anywhere here.
So I will have a state, because
I have picked phosphorus
carefully.
And because of the way the
chemistry and the bonding
worked with
phosphorus in silicon,
this will introduce a state
near the conduction band,
and that's the key.
So now we've got
the valence band,
and we've got the
conduction band.
And what's happened is
there's a new level here
that is called the donor level.
That level is where the extra,
extra key electron goes.
It can't go in here, remember.
This is all filled.
So now, I've doped
with P. But look,
if I've got an electron here,
now this difference in energy
is really small.
It's really small.
I've engineered it this way.
I've thought about it.
So if I put phosphorus in
here, that extra electron
isn't sitting far away anymore
from the conduction band.
In fact, now it's so close
that room temperature just
kicks it right on up.
So effectively, it's
going to go up here,
because that's a small
delta e between the donor
level and the conduction band.
This is how doping works.
So I put a phosphorus atom in.
There's an extra electron
that comes out of that.
The extra electron
needs a state.
It gets a state.
That's called a donor state.
Donor makes sense,
right, because it's
donating an electron
into the conduction band.
Once I get the electron into the
conduction band, I'm home free.
Because now, I've done what
temperature was doing before,
but I did it with chemistry.
And so you could ask
questions like this.
How much phosphorus do you
need to substitutionally dope?
Substitution meant
just what you--
substitution was I
took a silicon atom
and I substituted it.
That's substitutional doping.
To substitutionally
dope a mole of silicon
and get a free electron density
of 5 times 10 to the 17.
I'm going big here.
Because look,
temperature-- gesundheit.
OK, maybe I'm willing to run my
semiconductor in a really hot
room, my phone at 600 kelvin.
I'm still only at 10 to the 15.
I want 10 to the 17 now.
How much phosphorus do I need?
You can solve that problem.
I'll just write down
a couple of the steps.
So the volume of
one mole of silicon
is one mole times
28.1 grams per mole.
Oh, and I got the density
on there, too, right?
Divided by 2.33 grams
per centimeter cubed.
How did I get the density?
I looked it up in
the periodic table.
And so one mole of
silicon is going
to give me 12 centimeters
cubed of silicon.
One mole of silicon is
12 centimeters cubed.
I need 5 times 10 to the 17
electrons in the conduction
band per centimeter cubed.
You see why per centimeter
cubed is a good measure here.
So that means I need
12 times that total.
So I need 12 times that.
So I need 5 times 10
to the 17 P atoms.
Why do I need that
many P atoms, times 12?
Let me just write my units
here to be very careful.
P atoms per centimeter cubed
times 12 centimeters cubed.
That's how P atoms I need
in this mole of silicon
to get what?
It's one to one.
Because each P atom
had one extra electron.
Those other electrons
are in the bonds.
They're not going into
the conduction band.
It had one for one.
One electron went to this donor
state, went into the conduction
band per phosphorus atom.
So if I want that
many carriers, if I
want that many free electrons,
I need that many atoms.
Well, you guys can look up
the phosphorus grams per mole,
and you can get that this is
0.0003 grams of phosphorus.
That's really not much.
You see why it's called
an impurity, right?
You see why it's
called an impurity.
That's not much.
I have all this
silicon, and I only
need 0.0003 grams of
phosphorus, and I've
bumped up the number of
carriers by orders of magnitude.
Not only that, I've done
something really important,
as well.
And you can see
this, because now,
if I plot something
like temperature
versus number of carriers--
well, you saw the graph for
temperature before, right?
It was like this.
That's the graph from
a couple sides ago.
But now, if I do it with
chemistry, it's flat.
Until the temperature
gets really hot, I could--
give myself more room
here, because that's
kind of the point, right?
Number of carriers.
I can make this now flat.
From doping, from temperature.
And so you can see,
OK, at a certain point,
the temperature goes up, up, up.
And at a certain
point, the temperature
is going to be so hot that
I'm adding electrons, even
beyond this.
But you saw the temperatures
there, 1,000 degrees kelvin.
No, this allows me to have
a predictable, flat number
of carriers in the conduction
band no matter the temperature.
Just think about how
important that is.
Semiconductors are kind of
discovered in the 1800s.
But it wasn't until
physicists and chemists
were able to
control the band gap
and how to put carriers in
and out of it until they could
really work on the
semiconductor revolution, which
is what led to Snapchat.
Did I get it?
Snapchat is still used.
I knew that.
Slack.
Now, you can do the same
thing going the other way.
You can do the same thing
going the other way.
If I now put gallium, so if
I dope with gallium, well,
you see, gallium has
one too few electrons.
And so if I dope with
gallium, what I have--
so the gallium is there.
Where is it?
It's on the other side.
Where's silicon?
Silicon.
Phosphorus is over
there, group 15.
Silicon is group 14.
Gallium is group 13.
One fewer electrons,
but it really
wants to make those four bonds.
The material isn't
happy if you break one.
And so what does it do it?
It steals an electron.
It takes it.
It says, I need an electron to
be happy, so it takes one out.
And that's called an accepter
level, where what's happened
is the gallium has
actually pulled
an electron out of there.
And that leaves behind
a positive charge.
This is called a hole.
That's called a hole.
Think about it.
If I take an electron off of an
atom, it's positively charged.
If I take an electron
out of the VBM,
there's a positive
charge in there.
That's really important,
because these positive charges
effectively are like electrons.
They're like negative
charges, but they're positive.
So they also can conduct.
They also can conduct, right?
And that's really important.
So these are two
different types.
And you can imagine the
brilliance of the naming.
These are P type, because
it's a positive charge.
And these are N type, because
it's a negative charge.
Those are N type semiconductors.
What does that mean?
I've used a little chemistry,
sprinkled a little something
with extra electrons.
It's got negative charge
in the conduction band.
P type, P means positive.
It means that I have
introduced states here,
because I needed an electron.
I say, I need an extra one.
I'm going to grab
it from somebody.
I don't care who.
And so you create
a positive charge
in the valence band that
can conduct electricity,
just like a negative charge
in the conduction band can.
This is what the entire
semiconductor revolution
has been based on.
And really, so much
of the focus was
on simply taking these
elements-- in particular,
silicon and germanium.
But then, many, many more, as
I showed you in the LED graph,
many, many more have
been used to make,
to engineer, these simple--
what are seemingly simple
properties, the band gap
and the doping.
And so I'm not going to
go through this in detail.
I'm just leaving it
here so you have it.
But you get charts like this.
Here, you have, OK,
carbon is up there.
Well, if you dope it with boron,
you can see that it's P type.
You see that?
Because I've got one fewer
electron than carbon.
So I'm going to grab that
from the valence band,
create a positive charge P type.
I could also dope
silicon and germanium.
I'd say carbon,
silicon, germanium.
So I'm looking at
this middle column,
doping it with either side.
Why can't I put
aluminum in carbon?
Why didn't they list that?
Well, because if I try to put
an aluminum inside the carbon
network, the network
gets all messed up.
Doesn't fit.
So that's also important.
Can it fit?
But it's through this that
the semiconductor revolution
started.
It's only through this,
this kind of control
and this knowledge
of atomic orbitals,
really, if you think about it,
and the structure of the atom.
Now, I'm not going to
talk about transistors,
but this did lead to the
development of the transistor.
There's a really
nice video there.
It's, like, eight, nine minutes.
I suggest you wait until
your Friday night social.
But if I take a P type
and I take an N type
and I take a P type and
I put them together,
some really important
things happen.
So important that it
led to this, which
is the very first transistor.
That's a transistor.
It's a dope semiconductor,
one type, next to a dope
semiconductor, another type.
Now, those are
the three people--
Bardeen, Shockley,
and Brattain--
who won the Nobel
Prize for this work.
And that's the first transistor.
Does anybody know how many
transistors we make today?
Per second.
That's the only time
metric we can use.
Yeah, it's something
around 10 trillion.
We make 10 trillion
transistors per second today.
This is a big deal.
This started it all, and
it's all about chemistry
and the physics of this device.
This led to diodes
and photodiodes.
This led to the
whole revolution.
And what I want to point out
here is that this also led--
it called on chemistry.
So I love this chart.
Unfortunately, they
didn't update it,
but this is an Intel chart
that they used to show.
And what they're showing is
how are they making chips.
How much of the
periodic table do they
need to make the current chip?
Well, in the '80s, there's
almost nothing lit up here.
There's a little bit over
here that you can't see,
stuff we just talked about.
But look at the '90s
and look at the 2000s.
And today, it's 75% of this.
It's literally 75% of
this is in your phone.
Yeah.
Why?
The reason is exactly what
we've talked about today,
because they need
more and more and more
flexibility and ways
to tune the band gap
and the semiconducting
properties of these materials
and the doping.
Why do they need new ways?
Because they're making
them so darn small.
They're so small, it
gets harder to figure out
how to do it right, how to
do it in a way that's also
stable over time, for example.
So they need new chemistry.
This is a call to action
to the field of chemistry,
and chemistry responded.
And there's the
data on the cost.
I thought that was kind of cool.
So these are orders of
magnitude of cost and number
of transistors.
And I'll just say one
more why this matters.
Because the semiconductor
is also the same thing
we use to take
electricity from the sun,
to generate electricity
from the sun.
And you can imagine, you are
doing that in your goody bag.
You're literally using
this semiconductor
to generate electricity
by shining light on it.
Why is this important?
Well, I like this comparison.
All the coal, oil, and
gas known to humans
is what you get from the
sun in about 20 days.
This is the sun.
Now, we've seen the sun before.
This is how we see
it in our class.
The sun is a spectrum
of different wavelengths
and intensities.
And this is already
on planet Earth,
because you can see
those chemistries that
are in the atmosphere
have already absorbed.
Remember ozone down here,
helping us with UV radiation?
And out here, you've got a lot
of water and other things, CO2.
Those are absorbing.
That's why it
doesn't look smooth.
But the point is, I want to
semiconductor to absorb as much
of this as possible.
If I want a good solar cell,
I should absorb as much
of this as possible.
But the problem is that it's
a constrained optimization
problem.
So let's see, if I--
I'll just use this.
This goes back to
Bohr, by the way.
Remember, Bohr, I'm
absorbing light.
It's just now, I've
got an actual solid.
I don't have an atom.
I've got a solid, which
is what you need if you
want to generate a current.
I've got to hook leads up to it.
But my solid is a semiconductor.
And you can imagine, say, well,
if my gap were really, really
tiny, then any amount--
almost any amount
of this spectrum
would excite electrons.
And I might grab most
of that spectrum.
I might absorb most of it.
But the problem with that
is that, then, all of these
will thermalize, like I
said in the beginning.
Loss to heat.
So if my band gap
is really small,
I absorb a lot of the light,
but I lose most of it as heat.
If my band gap is really big,
then there's so much of this
light that I cannot absorb.
By the way, also, the
voltage that you get out
of your solar cell is
essentially this band gap.
So if I get to really,
really small band gaps,
I have almost no voltage.
That's bad, too.
But if my band gap
is too big, you
think, oh, I'll
get a high voltage.
No.
You won't absorb any photons.
So it's a constraint problem.
It's a constraint problem.
You can actually solve
this, and you can plot--
in fact, here's a
little animation.
Energy comes in from the sun.
It excites an electron.
This is how PowerPoint sees it.
Leaves behind a hole,
and you get them out.
That's a solar cell.
And this is the chart
I want to show you.
Because you see, if I take
this constraint into account,
that I don't absorb light
if the gap is too big,
but I do absorb
light and it all goes
to heat if the gap
is too small, it
means there's some sweet spot.
There's some sweet spot.
And that's what is plotted here.
This is the band gap
of a semiconductor,
and this is the maximum
that that solar cell
efficiency could be.
That's the maximum that
it could be for that gap.
So you can see the sweet
spot is right there.
That's a thermodynamic
derivation
called Shockley-Queisser
of the maximum efficiency
you could ever get out
of a single material.
And notice, if you put
the materials here,
silicon is 90% of the
solar cells you buy today.
And notice that it's not quite
at its maximum potential.
It's also not quite in the
middle, where you'd want.
It should have a
slightly higher gap,
and you'd get to
higher efficiency.
But these materials
out of gallium
arsenide, they do have the--
what is GS?
That's not an element.
Gallium arsenide, it
does have a better gap,
but it's much more expensive.
And so we go.
And a lot of solar
cell research is
on getting as close to
this point as you can.
See you guys on Friday.